in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Dan and
Kelsey dropped by from Charlotte North
Carolina huh question hey guys how are
you hey Dave we're currently working
hard on baby step six and as we look
towards buying real estate with cash
once our primary residents it's paid off
what is your suggestion as to when is
the best time to look at using a
property management group versus the
managing the rental yourself
well property management groups that do
a great job or like anything else you
have to search for them and you have to
make sure that the fees are reasonable
and that you know exactly what they're
going to do and what they're not going
to do you don't want to give them carte
blanche on repairs as an example
anything over a certain amount they need
to call you for and you look at what
you're paying them and say what would I
want to manage that the benefit of
managing it yourself is that you're
going to control the quality of tenant
a little differently they'll do a good
job screening you'll do it better
because it's your house and you'll
probably shop a little harder when the
repairs need to be done and you know you
know if they eating there guy says
sixteen hundred dollars you might go
what they might go okay you know I'm not
saying they're sloppy it's just not
their money and so but then the downside
is is the time that you're going to
invest and the heartache and the hassle
because the people are going to call you
when something's broken you got to go
over there and meet them you got to
screen them you got to get the lease
documents filled out you got to do all
of that and so the question is do you
want to fool with all that I grew up in
the business so it's second nature to me
and I personally managed our rentals for
a long time my son-in-law Winston runs
all of our real estate now we've got
quite a bit of real estate and he
manages all of it and matter fact he's
got staff that helps him manage all of
it
so we've got our own little in-house
private property management company so
to speak so I don't personally deal with
tenants anymore heaven in years but but
but I grew it to the point that I could
do that so but you know it's like
anything else you know DIY right you you
know there's a hassle factor involved
and and there's always an adventure
but you bring the professionals in your
job if you're going to use a property
management company if you get a good one
and you know they're gonna save you time
and heartache but you're going to pay
for that and so do you want to trade
some of that out then it's okay
that it's it's a trade out so I've got
you know good friends that use property
management companies and there are fun
and then own them and run them and they
they're fine companies they do a fine
job they're worth what they charge but
not if you're a pure DIY guy and it
would drive you crazy to you know every
time look one little thing comes up
you're gonna second-guess everything
then no you got to be hands-off and let
them do it and you know you check them
and you they check in with you you get
regular reports and so forth but that
that's that's the case I would do that
so hey thanks for dropping by guys
appreciate you coming by hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you